yeah let's talk about your book so you
just this is like
top of the charts uh number one
best-selling not was it fiction
non-fiction they did they erased all the
tweets no no you're right i look for it
so this
this is what happened and i have no uh
uh rational explanation
okay i did many of you guys know i was
just on jordan peterson's show uh not
that long ago we taped it a few months
ago it just dropped
i don't even mention this book in the
show at all so i just
how amazon works and can i get like five
minutes because this is something i
think it's me edifying because this is
an example
of how the regular person can take on
the publishing houses and win
okay if you want and it's unfortunate
it's going to be through amazon but
right now they basically have a monopoly
soon there's gonna be four or five
venues
how it works is you create your document
make sure you get a professional book
design and so on and so forth you upload
it to their create space site
they have to clear it and then once they
clear it it's on amazon to buy just like
any other book
the problem is when i sent them this
which is a collection people always ask
me andre cause
last week because i'm interested and i
would get bored with it i'm like i don't
have time to answer a question like you
know what
there is no book that people can go to
to get the complete idea of all the
calls of black flag so i'm like i'm
going to put together this book
historical essays
so they'd email me back they'd be like
we have a problem with this essay
when did this person die i'm like
michael bacon and died in like the 1800s
this is public domain
we have a question with this one and in
between it's three or four days
so you're sitting there you don't know
how many days it's gonna happen then
they're like it's live so if there's no
you can't have a release date my next
book i'm to get it cleared ahead of time
so that i can hit published on whatever
december 1st it drops
and no i didn't mention any of the shows
i did i didn't have a big push because i
didn't know when it was coming out
for a full day it was the number three
book on all of amazon
it was the top non-fiction book on all
of amazon number one was dr seuss
number two was some ladies novel number
three was me for it wasn't like a spike
because i did some show or someone
mentioned it
the fact that it's still so it was
beating obama it was beating hillary it
was beating
president trump it was beating oprah
everybody
and the only way this happened was
through fans
and word of mouth i still don't
understand how it happened because it's
asymptotic
it is much much harder to go from 20 to
10 than from 30 to 20.
you're getting steeper and steeper we
did it i'm delighted by the response
and this is a good example of how one
person with a motivated fan base
spreading the ideas of liberty as
opposed to libertarian party bro
i was on breitbart earl this week alex
marlow who's great he's got a book out
we're doing better sorry alex
he was reading a whole section of emma
goldman on breitbart
the fact that i could have people
talking about radical ideas
and people are hungry for radical ideas
it shows that there is a market for it
people love to talk about these concepts
but they're not usually allowed to in
corporate media
the lp wants none of it and that's why
they're a joke and that's why when i
take over it's going to be really funny
i think we were some of those fans you
were you guys pushed it it means a lot
well were you still chairman though i i
think i'd be chairman in the chinese
sense
okay so one of the things we we had said
right we keep getting super chats
where people are like they'll say
something innocuous and then turn it
into a pitch for michael nola's book
sure so they'll be like you know i can't
believe what they're doing with canceled
culture on social media
it's leaving me speechless much like
michael knows his book speechless
and uh whenever you know so we read them
and it is clever but i always say
uh you know so i've i've you know
chatted with michael a little bit and
he's just like oh man are they
they're they're still pushing that meme
and i was like it's fantastic i love it
yeah i want it i want everyone to buy
your book so it's the top of the charts
i want everyone to buy michael malus's
book
to the top of the charts i want everyone
to buy andy noe's book on mass top of
the charts
all of them then when regular people go
to amazon to find a book what are they
going to get
the most influential subjects are going
to be written by smart people
challenging the establishment and here
i'm going to let you guys in a little
inside baseball i've not told anyone
this is the first time revealing this
i got a call from one of the major major
publishers there's only four or five of
them
and and this is an editor i knew and he
goes your book got flagged
because whenever you have these
independent books that do gangbusters
it's our job to be like how did this
happen and he's getting on a call with
me and i like the guy but i'm going to
tell him
you guys are screwed there's nothing you
could do to fix your model
you're gonna go the way of warner
brothers atlantic records which back in
the day there are four or five record
labels
all the records are through them now you
guys still have a large proportion
just like abc cbs and nbcf of sitcoms
but in terms of channels there's not
only a cable
like dozens on youtube it's literally
infinite
you are never going to be in a position
to be
random house or st martins or simon
schuster the way you were
because i right now have demonstrated to
you
and i'm not magic that i could go there
and beat you at your own game and here's
the other thing
let's suppose that they can run the
table on me if i sold this book to them
on january 1st
it would come out january 2023 what
happened was in february a fan of mine
marla
said look there hasn't been a book like
this the last one that was like this in
the 60s wasn't you that audiobook
and i said why don't you just do it from
scratch and it was out in may
so that turnaround is something they are
not in a position to do
so this book is it's a collection of
essays correct by a bunch of famous
anarchists and you're going to read one
i am going to read one of the classic
essays shortly after we wrap up here in
the audiobook
and but but is is is there like a lot of
original
from you in this no this is so the whole
point of this is people always ask me if
anarchism is from an authority on the
subject haha
the slogan i have on the back is the
black flag comes in many colors
this has been a long historical
tradition that is swept under the rug
there's very many variants there's the
hardcore narco communists which in many
ways are predecessors to antifa
there's the contemporary and arc
capitalists which the left wings do not
consider anarchists at all
but this just shows alternatives to
government
and critiques of government from many
different points of view let me ask you
about the political compass right people
people like to say that antifa is the
left libertarian quadrant
and that i would say libertarian left
certainly yeah right definitely not
libertarian right um
people like you just mentioned an
article communist for the precursor to
antifa sure i'm not i i don't believe
that those who would use force to impose
their will over others would be
classified as
libertarian or anarchist but they would
certainly be anarchists like the guy on
the cover lewis ling his essay he was
arrested by illinois
for being for making bombs and he's
explicitly set up for force
so their vision this was their argument
and i i
since we're on youtube i'm going to be i
have to make clear this is historical
stuff
there's nothing i'm endorsing people
doing it's not something i personally
believe in
but their argument because they came out
of a communist tradition which is not
marxist
so i would strongly encourage all the
people who are libertarians who read
this the one essay they love the most
is by michael bakunin from 1867. bakunin
was marx's big rival
for the international left and his essay
50 years for the soviet union
said this is what marxism is going to
mean in practice this is why it's a
nightmare a thousand times worse than
the czar
you guys are crazy you guys are evil
this is not what we're about he called
it it's all in here
so they were for force in this sense
their argument was which again i don't
agree with
that because the police and the
government are
tools of the wealthy to exploit the
population and to keep
poor laborers starving and can't feed
their kids remember this before the
welfare state
it is our job to use weaponry as
self-defense
to have this revolution to have you guys
not keep bleeding us dry so so
in that regard perhaps i agree with you
that they were the precursor to antifa
which i view as an overtly authoritarian
left movement because they attack
regular people
correct so they would not be in favor of
that
any of the people in this book would not
be in favor of that right right right so
that i guess that's my distinction the
modern version of the people who claim
to be left libertarian are anything but
and let me also defend these commies
from a lot of these article capitalists
emma goldman who i love was deported by
woodrow wilson via j edgar hoover
in the uh during the great war and sent
to russia
and she goes there because the argument
is when push comes to shove these people
are going to be stalinists
she goes to russia she's looking around
she's like this is not where we're about
this is a disaster
she goes to lenin's office yells at him
she goes
we're anarchists we're we are for free
speech before the maximum freedom of
individual what are you guys doing he
goes free speech he told her her face
free speech is a bourgeois contrivance
at the very least you can't have it
during periods of revolution so go home
emma
her mentor karpotkin was under house
arrest you know in the soviet union
she left with her partner in crime
literally crime alexander berkman
they each wrote books denouncing this
and emma's was called my disillusionment
in russia
when she went to britain emma goldman
the heroin the left she's the you know
this is as left as it gets
she gave a speech she starts with a
standing ovation
she's like guys what's going on the
soviet union is a nightmare
this is exactly what we're opposed to
this is horrible from beginning to end
when she was done you could hear you
could hear a pin drop because they
weren't hearing it
because they were more than happy that
this is going to be a big theme in my
next book to have all these russians
over there
let's have it be an experiment listen if
if it doesn't work
who cares it's the russians it's not
affecting us and if it works then we get
to import it
so this was really cynical sick stuff
and when ayn rand uh who escaped the
soviet union was on donahue in 1979 i
tweet this all the time
donahue says to her how are you so harsh
against these people
how are you just condemnatory can't just
say you disagree why did you call them
so evil she goes
because i look at them because they
don't hesitate to sacrifice whole
nations
and more recently in our time venezuela
which you mentioned
how many people were like hell yeah hell
yeah hell yeah venezuela what's going on
there
and then later they weren't like what if
i i could i would
have i would be perfectly fine with them
being like you know what
just like goldman or berkman they're
like i thought this was going to be
great
and look how it turned out i was wrong
and we really need to have saladara
people venezuela especially as leftists
we should worry about poor people and
there's none of that pin drops
i went to venezuela uh stores were empty
it was very very difficult to buy things
we went to a mall if you can call it
that and it was just a bunch of empty
stores and some were open
we did go to some areas that you know
had food there were wealthier areas
luke also went to venezuela someone was
literally shot and killed as soon as i
landed at the airport
and yeah at the airport at the airport
the airport is one of the most dangerous
places you could
be in caracas venezuela why is that uh
that's where all the major robberies and
crimes happen and an egyptian guy was
literally just just
a couple of minutes in front of me
leaving the airport some guys tried to
mug him he resisted they shot it
i heard the shot as i was going through
customs but i wanted to point crazy
venezuela
luke posted a bunch of videos of these
markets that were just barren
yeah but there were leftists american
leftists who went to venezuela and went
to the potemkin markets
and filmed all the glory of all their
products saying how great it was
the chavista areas right the communist
friendly areas that that
were of course friendly with the regime
this is what people don't realize sorry
when you go to these countries the
government runs everything they also are
perfectly happy
they have the 90s north korea and many
other places they're like okay we've got
enough food for 500 people
we've got uh 2 000 people who's going to
get the food they're not going to say
we're going to do it equally
they're going to take care of their own
first in a way you can't blame them
because they don't take care of their
own they're going to lose their hold on
power and therefore
not continue the revolution so from
their perspective they don't have a
choice
it's horrifying and again what we talked
about earlier americans have
no clue what this is like but my next
book's gonna change are there ways to
dissolve monarchy that aren't
violent well yeah they could abdicate
decentralized
every problem we see comes from
centralization comes from big
governments comes from people
saying that they're going to fix
everyone's problems and that's
impossible we have to
realize and wake up as a people and
understand that one person shouldn't be
responsible for everyone else and we
should all be responsible for ourselves
personal responsibility yes yep or
call your friend hire someone it doesn't
you know like people are like oh in
anarchist society you'd be the first one
shot i'm like
why don't i have the ability to call in
my big mma friends
to be like hey can you uh be my
housemate well hold on hold on
if the idea was that criminal punishment
deters crimes
why do we still have crimes right we've
got very harsh problems we got what is
it like a quarter of the world's prison
population is here in the us
it's unconscionable there were several
studies that the death penalty was not a
deterrent for people committing extreme
crimes
i i look at it this way when it comes to
like gun rights specifically
i sometimes cross busy streets cars
don't hit me you know why
they have brakes surprise surprise the
individuals driving those cars don't
want to kill somebody
right it's not because of the law it's
because they don't want to kill somebody
and also let's be completely sociopathic
about it they don't want the headache
from damaging their car
so even if they don't value your life
there's still going to be a cost for
them in terms of like why
i'd rather the break than having a day
of having drill with his blood
it's let's let's uh it's when people get
desperate is when they change
no one really wants to hurt until
they're starving and they need
a degree and everything's in their way
there's a lot of evil people out there
who get off and hurting like children a
lot of sociopaths most
of them are in washington dc per capita
the most largest amount
this is why my uh new political ideology
is called marxism
and it's where we take elon musk's
starship whenever someone
uh we take all of congress and all the
politicians they go in the ship
and then it blasts off then what
what do you mean
he just told you that's it it's gone
i just watched you know what happens
next we all live happily ever after
applause and then what we do is
whenever someone wins a position in
office we have smaller rockets and
they blast off so you won
congratulations right this way sir
adios let's go to super chat to serve
government
it must be done i was going to bring up
tehran but uh we have chats
oh yeah yeah that's where they ban
politicians in a mexican city with 30
000 people
they ban politicians political slogans
political signs
and people deal with their problems
through a community one-on-one basis
and it's one of the largest anarchist
places in the world chiron mexico i did
a full documentary on it on my youtube
channel we are change and it's worth a
watch because the ideas expressed there
have been carried out with large
populations in a peaceful cohesive way
with people taking personal
responsibility for themselves and
standing up
to government to the cartels and to the
police officers that were all corrupted
and doing horrible things to the
community and now they're living in
peace
where literally homicides down
completely
murders stopped completely uh kidnapping
stopped completely all because people
decided to take their life into their
own personal hands can i give you some
unsolicited advice yeah uh for you and
everybody else if you're doing something
like this
get a url that would be easy to remember
so instead of going to we are changed
you just go to like iranian
documentary.com they go straight to it
so that's a cheap easy way to
promote stuff uh i i'm really big
proponent of that all of our sponsors we
do that yeah
number two is uh i don't think people
like the ancoms
they get something a lot of stuff right
because human beings are not lord of the
flies despite what we're told in
hobbsion
when you look at survivor the only
reason these people are fighting is
because they have to vote each other out
when people tend to be in communities
for the
most part which is like 90 which is a
huge percentage they really don't want
headaches they don't want conflict they
just want to get along
and like sometimes like okay my
neighbor's noisy am i really going to
call the cops even judge judy
berated one of the pla the plaintiffs or
defendants once she goes
i'm like i'm she's like i'm 900 years
old i've had lots of neighbors some i
like
some i don't like some are annoying some
are not annoying whatever
i've never called the cops in any of
them because when you're dealing in a
community you have to
anyone who lives in the city you have to
have some some little sacrifices so
i think people don't appreciate to what
extent
cooperation is the norm like you see a
kid
it's just kind of it's just taken for
granted thanks for checking out this
clip from the tim cast irl podcast
if you want to see the full show come
back to this channel youtube.com
tim cast irl monday through friday at
8pm where you can leave comments
and super chat and we actually will read
your comments
on the show don't forget to like share
subscribe and if you want exclusive
members only content segments you can't
get anywhere else
go to timcast.com become a member and we
even have full bonus episodes
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time